this is a production of Cornell
University so I'm going to talk about is
Rick and these are the various topics of
them through up with most of the
emphasis on the data part are the most
useful for you so before I get started
to show you our homepage and obviously
there's our there's our address and this
is the place you like to go you want to
find anything we'll talk here about
later on about how we can find the data
how you can utilize in our capacity
building so we'll go through these
topics okay so let's just say what is
history is an independent foundation and
yeah 1966 there's a lot of information
and the Dutch government is saying well
we're a small country we don't have a
lot of money to do that is International
said well we can find a small Institute
that's a reference Institute linking
with the rest of the world and still has
the core funding of the Dutch government
as development support so it comes from
the Ministry of Foreign Affairs the core
funding so the concept is this is
supporting the international
international community it's basically
coming in the room and some people say
how do you say that well study Dutch for
a while before you denounce it
so if you get to the railway station and
ask particulars the important point here
is that
it's accredited as the world of data
center resort so in the international
network of official data centers there
for meteorology for land date or
whatever this has got the official
mandate from the international community
you see our staff there it's not a very
big institution and this is our current
current lineup of nationalities we seem
to have a can be representation with
southern Europeans but that's okay we're
all your in there
we have PhD students but they're always
in linking with other universities both
in the Netherlands or for example b1
cooperation University China we also
have a guest researcher program so
that's something you can come in sit
with us and work for a while on projects
there's a lot of partnerships as I say
this is an international organization so
I've listed a few here you're not part
of often a university they do panels on
the administration there's a cooperative
free Memphis common campus so that's the
relation you see the other ones here and
you'll see are there variables these
large international collaborations
having to deal with data and in some
cases the more specific soils data for
example the desert of vacation in their
concentration this is our mission
mission then we'll talk about these
different things here I mean along the
outside are the different kinds of
applications the soil the center which
I've circled here the world reference
collection the soil data these are the
really key point they then go out to be
used in these other areas so let's talk
first about the standards since history
is an international institution it's
interested in international standards
and these are some of the topics we deal
with all with institutional partners
that also have interested in standards
and the ideas and they all these
standards open you see various ones and
for example in the soil class
you may not be aware but there is an
international small classification
classification international being
that's all science which is called the
world reference basements all resources
this has got a working group fact right
now the head of the one who has a link
University Munich but Israel has been
involved in this from the days of the
FAO map of the world so yeah I just have
a common soil classification that
national systems and then relate so this
is the kind of thing that district is
it's very very active in and I just
those who are not familiar with it
thought I'd show just information sheet
its revised on an eight year cycle so
the international meetings so we have
the data to support the 80 of these
systems we have a project and soil
laboratory interoperability you see are
some of our partners here sine row and
land care in New Zealand they're very
interested in standards the Israelis
been doing this for a very long time
there was a very large inter laboratory
collaboration exchange of the samples
magnets and decent sixties em if you go
back and read those reports it makes
very compressing reading how how
inconsistent labs are so labs are always
thinking about this and nowadays with
spectroscopy it comes in if you have
another thing in the lab these are the
collaborating labs you see them it's a
bunch of bunch of logos of the global
open data for agriculture is something
called go down and the concept here is
to have data that could be used for all
kinds of applications that are opened
for anybody to use for their
applications so this is a little bit I
call it like a public version of grow
intelligence or these other commercial
companies which are quite Moody
subscribe to and they try to help people
understand state of Agriculture but
these various organizations
see I see a are instead and so forth
all in all so we're one of the
organizations so that's about about the
standards now the main reason for is for
it to exist is the beta so I say the
resource for quality control data are
the souls of the world it means of
course you can get data from different
national organizations international
organizations companies and so forth but
who is going to put them into one
database try to harmonize them and this
is what history is really it's the
original mandate in what we call the
analog age is the reference collection
of profiles show that a little bit later
they were actual profiles collected with
full laboratory data and reference
sheets so you could see all the
information about specific points of
data digital age obviously there's an
expanded mandate and the idea now is to
serve to any client point data
I call it points because of course it's
got zero dimensional geo-reference
patterns and now as I said we're getting
there's the site descriptions field
information lab information and now
increasingly spectroscopy but any of
this is available we serve that and we
also are now serving gridded maps
soul products so far just properties and
classes and we're interested in
expanding this into making gridded maps
of salt functions so for example love
water to groundwater that kind of carbon
storage capacity and so that's not yet
done but that's now part of the mandate
the key point here is it's meant to be
on a global basis it's meant to be
consistent on a global basis here's a
picture of our reference collection list
of typical I think this picture because
I think this is the easiest sort of
monolith one that ever make this isn't a
sand dune in Suriname
it was probably fairly easy to compare
this model
but anyway you prepare the model if we
pack it up and you bring it back to
marketing and you know while you've got
all the lab information and this then
becomes your breakfast question now
there are 1100 of these sitting some on
a museum which I'll show later later
some its storage are all there they're
all currently being scanned through the
very high high high resolution flatbed
scanner right down to where you can see
I'm not sorry I forget the resolution
and certainly the millimeter level
you're able to see all the structure and
so forth they're all you scan and this
is just a picture of where there's some
the next thing is our digital database
which we call losest which is world soil
information system as of September 2019
all these points represent profiles of a
system now you'll notice there's some
big gaps some of the gaps are because
and because think of Australian very
little very little has been has been
done here in the way of solving
observations or Siberia dispara
another gaps here are because the data
cannot be freely shared on their
licensing minute but this gives you some
concept of the density of data there's a
nice Journal article if you'd like to
research our neuroscience data 2017 that
explains explains all this and you can
see the title providing standardized
profile data the world so the concept
here is when you get the database and
download it it's all documented so that
you know what methods were used for
measurements you can then you can
combine these all in whatever kind of
model might want you the flow is
interesting we we are very good at
collecting we don't tell people you
don't have to do extra work to give us
your data give us a date of the way it
is because you probably don't have funds
or you don't have time to give us raw
data any anyway you have it so we
actually
contributions from national sorcery
organizations NGOs development projects
so give us your soil data it's often the
only source of rescue install program
that is the original database gets lost
but we still have it so I'm going to
give it to us better we'll take any data
structure or format as long as its
document so I don't care if it's in hill
with GIS or it's Excel sheets or
whatever as long as we have it and we
know what it is that we can start it's
not yet in our database but we collected
it and we pressed and a very important
point is with any license so there are
different restrictions on soils data
depending on the country and therefore
we have to respect that as an
international organization we have to
respect for those licenses and we're
quite experts in not violating sometimes
obscure licenses why would you give us
data we can't publicize it's sort of we
can use it in our own products so for
example estimates of global carbon stock
we'd like as many points as possible and
we can use points that are given to us
for our use but that we can't
unfortunately cannot share with you to
make your own estimate of global carbon
ladies right so so we can take them any
format then the next stop is
standardization and harmonization what
we mean by it is we do not make
transfers so for example if you measured
phosphorus one way we told ourselves use
petrol transfer functions what we do is
we document which method you use so
every measurement in our database comes
with a link to how it was done so then
it's up to you to figure out you can say
maybe I only want to pick the
measurements that were made with a
certain method did that or I'll take
them all I know they are so when I say
standardization what I mean is it's in
one constant database format and the
harmonization means that you now have a
method to decipher carbonate we have two
versions we have snapshots so we make
sense
shots that we think are going to be
useful for over watering and then we
have always the latest version as for
adding and adding we have a lot of
consistency checks in quality that is
really important because you'll get a
database and it says the pH was 22 you
think that's probably not right there
are lots of kinds of checks like this
and we're constantly adding checks both
in individual deals but also cross
checks so you know we've got a lot of
free iron you know we wondered who's
that consistent this pH we're trying to
implement checks of course you're still
responsible for making your own checks
right where we try to limit to the
database
Thanks check managing intellectual
property rights so in the database that
we do give you in there are still some
restrictions sometimes you have oh that
you can use it for a dry product even
you can't show them France is a really
bad problem we had a recent paper where
we made a product using only the data we
can get our answers with 85 points or
something the French shoot over 2000 and
they said our atmosphere
so yeah well I think that might make
sense because of the privacy law in
France is you're not allowed to show
locations of solar profiles for its
privacy data so this is the kind of
stuff that happens
so we manage that very well this is an
example for rescue I you have to know
who sent me there for to help them to
find a project for the soil information
system I went to visit the AG agency and
they said oh yeah we had an Australian
project here's ago and we have it on a
disk we have no idea what to do with it
so I got a copy of the data which are
the sort of all the or pink dots here
and they said and then we sent them a
memorandum of understanding and they
signed this is sure we're happy users
let's look at this give no sir and so
now the state of all these cambodian
data you know other points which
once we're all in our database the
Australians don't have it that project
is all over I think the hard disk got
lost this is not an isolated example of
us rescue data so please if you dig it
through from your older projects we'll
take we have a web service for easy
access this is a map of using web
feature feature service this is what the
address is these are just some of the
profiles that you could get so you can
get it directly into your GIS file web
feature service oh man I have written a
couple of documents how do you use this
is me on how you would access Moses
directly from the latest version just
right bring it so you can bring it in
your GIS because or you can just
download a recent development of course
is spectroscopy and very interesting now
is a variety of reasons and so history
is not moving into this area of trying
to collect these and include them on our
database for now we only have agreement
with ASUS which was aircraft in Kenya
but we're trying to agreements with the
Americans to try to get their data and
get other people's we try to have a
global data set of reference
spectroscopy so glad the spectroscopy in
the lab data side-by-side but you'll
have it for the whole world so we're
trying to move into that now I talked
about the Koreas and our grinnin project
is something called soil roots and we're
now at 250 meter resolution originally
was one kilometer this was a kind of
interesting project that was started by
one of my former PhD students PC
students and he got working in history
and there was a project to do something
called global soil map that it
supposedly was going to make a global
song map and it never really got started
very well because it was depending on
regional nodes to coordinate data
different
and for political reasons it never give
up I mean we never for example to get a
South Asian note the Indians don't trust
the Pakistanis and Pakistanis the
Indians everyone ignores the Sri Lankans
etc I mean there was no reason there was
no regional structure possible there and
then another area so the Chinese for the
note in China but the Japanese didn't
really want to give their native the
Chinese and so he worked that very
alertly international organizations I
didn't was get all the data we have and
use this to make minute a map of the
entire world consistent basis so you can
see what this is it's a machine learning
process is all open access this was the
article on the current version so the
first author Tom Anglo was my PhD
student he since has left his rent and
started his own company so we're now
have we're now working on the second
version that's we've got it at this
point as a trial version in April the
second version will come out with some
improvements but this explains the idea
of very relative
these are the data we make available so
all of these things you see here are
predicted for the whole world well not
maybe not Antarctica for 80 to 80
degrees the 250 meter grid now the
question is how good is this data it's
unclear we use consistent global models
from the data we have to try to predict
but obviously when you're using it a
given spot it's only a prediction but
it's a lot better than some things
because you often have an area where
especially in countries that have no
never made soil mass what are you going
to do want to know something Pierre
Hobbs just wrote me wants to meet me
when he gets back from England he's
working some villages and tons in the
end he says I need to know something
about the soils there what do I do
well I may help him find maps kinds of
you know we have in our reference
collection but you can always look at
this and find an idea and seven standard
nips
right so by death the basic idea of
digital saw mapping is in this slide we
have points we know where they are where
we measured information about them at
different depths we get a bunch of
covariance if you think represents soil
forming packs this is standard this is
not just history everyone doesn't so we
have vegetation geology and climate etc
that may well be influencing soils and
then we build some kind of machine
learning algorithms to make these these
predictions there's a lot of technical
details here and that's why we are
updating the current version is based on
over 102 Castle solo profiles and then
so but all the depths we have this name
of measurements we have a problem
because there are some areas we didn't
really have a place so we had to add
pseudo points in some cases like the
middle Becerra desert to try to get
certain combinations of soil properties
and environment that had not been
actually sampled so there's a lot of
detail in here but the key point here is
these models for better or worse or
global models so this is based on
there's a theory of salt formation if
the conditions are the same in Brazil as
in Angola we should have to say okay if
we could not get the variables that
actually represent it that's a bit of a
questionable but not too questionable so
just realize if you do this at a local
level we've always said if you have a
local level with local covariance local
points and you have specific situations
if you have good example is in our area
of New York State any glaciated areas is
difficult to find covariance over the
whole place with you more hard if you
were doing in bigger state you have no
problem or any of coverages that
represent the different deposits the
Marines the ages and so we don't have
that for model Siberia so we can't use
it until a little longer
so be aware that this is based on
covariance
we have to have for the whole world to
be able to use fun the methodology that
we use elsewhere this is just some
examples of what co-variants a little of
itself this is a list of some of the
coheeries that are used to get some
ideas of things that are related to soil
formation of salty otter so and we're
always constantly looking now to access
soil grids from the website and you can
see you have all these layers or
continuing and you could then show it as
a map you can also download all these
use it here's an example of soil carbon
stock in 30 is 30 to 60 centimeter layer
in some areas in Indonesia Malaysia and
Singapore right so good example and each
of these little dots every grid every
grid has has a number you might or not
might or not have believe in number but
neat soils here Marsh soils unity now
the future developments is actually
going on right now as I say and these
are the solid things we're doing we're
very interested in is quantifying the
uncertainties because we know that not
everywhere I'm absolutely good we know
that actually from our machine learning
models from cross-validation so we have
a good estimate of the uncertainty and
we're trying to make that inform a big
challenge now is putting in the form to
understand as we understand wonders have
been certainly pretty well confidence
limits means and standard deviations
quantiles but the users seem to have a
many users seem to have a really hard
time understanding that straight we're
trying to make that in the presentation
other mental map of them primary value
in the uncertain even in the way people
probably is ranging I told you that we
were thinking of soil functions and
that's going to be the next step and we
always have new covariance so the
Sentinel satellites is a really nice new
system try to develop covariance that
might be better
so that is our so we've our point
product most
a great project so crits all freely
available for you to use and I would say
about in soil there is if you're going
out and working in area
I'd recommend don't get it so busier
area and using as a reference you can
then overlay and then be better off okay
we're in some capacity building one
thing we have is the world so music
Honus the world zones in David it's like
I would say it's a religious obligation
like evil one time to like to go to
Mecca if you're able if you don't you
know one time you know don't really have
to buy anyway we've set this up very
nicely with displays mainly for
education as I said we have 1100 both
model is and rollin baby 80 here
organizing the school groups come in all
the time from the Netherlands all the
way down from junior high school right
up to graduate students they come they
bring them students from Germany and I
eligible to come and see it and of
course visitors families you know and we
were open if you come please I'll take
you in tours of any language I'm we have
a vertical strong using so maybe this is
a little easier we as I don't fairly
detailed stance and we're almost done
with all 1100 profiles with their data
and you can do a detailed scan station
we run some schools we have a spring
school every year on digital song
mapping part and we'll saw mapping part
here's heavily good getting a lecture
and we do a lot of tailor-made trainings
so that any common project go back to
our country to the client I mean
training
for example soil databases we're very
good at helping national organizations
set up their soil databases they want to
having people who want to learn digital
soil mapping projects another part of
capacity building that's underrated is
the online library is online now that's
course there's a physical library one of
the things we started doing way back was
collecting great literature as you know
a lot of work on soils is grey
literature
Cornell's does a nice job of collecting
the things where we've been involved but
there are many many projects were
Cornell people are so involved in this
Rick went way out of their way to
collect this so we have 20,000 books and
reports most of them are great
literature so an example we have 10,000
may perhaps you know a nice project a
number of years ago thanks the European
research jrc of the European Commission
they offered with their own money to
scan all of our nets and they haven't
put out in a series of CDs and online
from actually human by the GRC but we
have an institute so all our paper map
collection is available as very
high-resolution scans so that's all been
done and we have these downloadable
documentation this is the number of
downloads per month you see this is our
library is integrated in botany and
university library goodness say for
example here you know so lower part of
Hunan province monograph 1992 I don't
know if you're even going to find it
anywhere in China reference profiles of
the People's Republic of China so you
can look through here find data and you
can just go online through the entire
library sq there's information on are
you working on and here's this example I
found Democratic Republic of Congo
back in Belgian days back before
independence the Belgians were quite
some effort in trying to make some soil
surveys and I put this example because
my PhD supervisor Armen Bombay was one
of the sole surveyors actually graduated
from university 1940
sit down he's the one who making things
go back along with me the first one so
if you see that one so happened then he
was in Congo and so there are quite some
maps and you're gonna have a little bit
of work working on this because there's
no geo reference you know your GIS I
hope you know how to get this in your
system you'll have this whole report and
here's a report that was done for just
paper it was just a presentation at some
meeting where everyone runs and his
colleagues said well well we're going to
survey well actually with dr congo is an
some hunt later hey that's a perfect
reference if you're ever going to go
work on the DR Congo what kind of social
surveys are available this has never
been published it's no great literature
of the diet so please before you go out
look in our database and see what you
can find about your country be surprised
the last point is we are involved in the
application so obviously we have this
reference database that you can get and
you can use for everything but our
experience is and I'm sure all the soil
scientists you're gonna regulate to this
users don't always understand soil data
very well you don't really understand
how to use it correctly they don't
understand is you invitations there are
some technical issues for example they
have no idea that what the different lab
that is just just as a simple example or
they may not realize really what you can
do and how how can I figure out the
irrigation potential from the things
that are in this database was classic
thing so we do a lot of work
interdisciplinary with partners where we
don't try to do project ourselves we try
to provide small data and the expertise
on how to properly interpret this data
in collaboration apartment now the
partner is already experienced in using
this data then we just have to show them
how to get to our data there's a lot of
often cases we have a lot of experience
and then our staff of a
in different areas the partners bring
the application we're very being on this
in the Netherlands now my colleague puts
this in every paper he writes the
sustainable development goals of
supporting I should back up and stay
since we're international we have to
follow the international trends that is
the UN says this is what we're doing
history gets on board from for obvious
reasons because it's trying to respond
to international mandates and the
sustainable development goals made you
may quibble with them they may not be a
realistic I never liked the word
sustainable anyway because in a certain
point the Sun is going to expand and
swallow the earth so all the over we
have my summarize ability he since
retired means now very back to the
Europeans soil soil policy let's say and
he's written a very nice paper here the
challenge this also has the need to
apply espied we use this as really a
guidepost circle the ones where do you
think souls you know and i think we
should try it i mean i think we should
see here in the structure I think we
should be gender equality I don't know
doesn't a less possible consumption I
don't know why you only circle deep
anyway you can see that soils can come
in at many ways I think that's the point
and what we're trying to do is make
aware of the people who work on these
problems not only then soils data can
help them with it but we have soules
data you can use as you and models use
we regard of something called the global
soil partnership which was an initiative
of the FAO again the FAO we're not
affiliated with the FAO because we have
our own mandate we're not in the United
Nations United Nations district is not
it's got an international mandate
the Scythians Council of scientific
Indians so it's international but not
tied to the FAO so we're partners of
this and so this is a lot of
applications this were involved in and
here's some examples of papers from us
that have applied for a specific
application and of course Africa is a
high interest for a lot of reasons
there's money there and here's for
example a soil nutrient maps in
sub-saharan Africa based on the soil
bridge product in this case specialized
gravity at this resolution and using
various models harmonized so here we
have the example I'm showing here is
extractable zinc and there had to be
some procedures during this to be
converting the different types of zinc
measurements to do one standard
extractable thing then using this in our
model area you see some of our
collaborators here from for example to
Shepherd from here craft and so forth
the first two people are from history
geography here's another one mapping
bootable Neptune with some plan
available ro Cassidy here we have a
plant available water capacity and
milliliters here we have and this is an
interesting what is the limiting factor
from in depth yeah is it is it is it a
chemical factor or is there a physical
factor is iteration so drainage so what
you're looking here it's a kind of
product we've made for our data based on
demand in collaboration with a
specialists innocent you know one again
go on main artists whose art scientists
kid a lot of experience working in
Africa as a salt scientist before II
joined us from years ago examine we are
also involved in industry this is a very
interesting project there's a company
called humility in the prospect which
was a moroccan originally to exploit
moroccan phosphate
thank and they are they came to us with
this problem they say you're willing to
invest in fertilizer plants but we want
to know what kind of blends should we
recommend and which areas so is there a
big enough area here where we put a
plant here this week the blend not a
soul in this area for blend so they use
our data so we have a project to try to
and they've been so successful our
original project i think was Mali and
Burkina Faso and we just signed to be
contractors so this is collaboration
with a commercial company but the final
application that I will show here is
this example of one of these big
projects they're rising 2020 project in
China so quality application developing
mobile phone amethyst all in just a few
more pictures of some of the other
things we didn't so you'll get some
feeling for the kind of projects that
the concept is here that in these
projects they they're not about soil so
marginal lands for growing industrial
crops this is actually in Europe yeah we
have a similar Brian Richards and these
guys are doing it here at Cornell's same
ideas market land well the soil and the
soils and the big affect on what kind of
crops you tomorrow etc as we well know
so we get involved that project provide
that so in conclusion please I hope
you'll walk out of here remembering
history world soils data please think of
us we're part of the adversative set
international standards we provide in
system quality control and
geo-referenced information soils we're
your trusted partner for training so
please think of us if you have a
training needs and as a partner for
value-added thank you
[Applause]
yes thank you very much it was great I
think it's out mr. ekeus is a huge
treasure profile in Leo but in the
minute you step to me Internet age
because I was and for making the data
available I think you touched on a very
important point of of the rights to the
data and that some of them you can
collect but every line a firewall and
that's of course a big problem that will
create future big problems and does it
relate to that we still struggle to have
soils as a common good like water in the
air he's not leading the charge again to
make source as a common good you has
tabled it a few years ago but but how
can we help you move forward with with
soils and soil information to be shared
freely and you mentioned global soil map
or yeah scope abscess is not yet really
cleared
there's a lot of and how do we move
forward when you're ready bring that to
actually I thought about this a long
time ever since I was a surveyor North
Carolina and I'm walking across
somebody's private land and I'm sampling
in soil or her soil as the case may be
and and I am now telling the whole world
after we've now we make our salon that
anyone can now take that soil map look
at that and first off you can tax them
hey but really in some countries like
Germany where the tax is based on land
quality
hey I know I wasn't actually I can look
at what land I want to buy
we're definitely in soils violating
privacy if we think of privacy in terms
of absentee writings of a landowner
that's a bad way now in a communist
country by Eastern Europe Eastern Europe
is a very good example communism was
very good for soil sciences Europe a
huge amount of money because Marxism
beliefs in science started that's
actually ideological so a lot of money
went into science and there was no
problem with private ownership z ology
of communism the land belongs to
everybody
they're more or less put into the state
the Communist Party as opposed private
so I think we have to think about how we
position soils data in terms of privacy
I think that's a deeper question because
for example some of these laws like
French law is explicitly based on you
know either privacy of the landowner
it's considered what's called a trespass
insanely you can't just walk onto that
land although I'm a big believer in
Scotland's right to ramble when I retire
that's when I find if you try to get
away to ramble or in New York State but
seriously it's a common good but it's
also and I agree with that you'd have to
say listen differently all the the water
quality in the Chesapeake Bay affects us
all so the fact that is your farm up
here in Tioga County I don't care that
it's your farm I need to know about that
because I need to make a model of water
quality it's a whole different mentality
other side's national security issues
you mentioned China I can tell you
because I work in China I had on my
computer at one point it was also there
the most recent series dated my boss
told me please take that off before you
mean China because actually my really
I'm not even sure I can look at this
anyway although you here as a guest
researcher
it's considered a safe secret it's I
don't know what you know India well
enough said
so I think there's a lot to do with got
a much higher level than we can deal
with of concepts of privacy and concept
of natural conventional security and I
agree with you that if there is some
thought that this is a common good and
public the benefits to the common would
but of course in the United States did
this thing about having double
citizenship you really kind of split
down in the middle of they asked me when
I got my Dutch citizenship well there's
a war between the Netherlands and us
what but you see that the US has this
founding myth of individualism and
privacy that is very deep in the culture
and I'm not talking right or wrong I'm
saying it's so in the culture to change
that whereas the Netherlands has much
more socialist era thinking of thinking
about resources right so no farmer and
the Netherlands would say my farm only a
concerns me they very clear that their
farm concerns the environment or Alice's
and he liked it but they're very aware
it's like these are deeper you ask a
really interesting question that's a
deep question
sorry it's a long answer to a good
question normal David I got a question
back to the in terms but the lack of
clear understanding on what the date
actually means are you guys actually
thinking about how you're going to
communicate information or at this point
it's just this is what the model says no
nobody's very it's in each other tongue
each application is different so I guess
when we get to the sole function key
you've got to then there would be a full
explanation of how we combine well
actually for the neutron that is already
there look at the paper and you can see
how we went from our
basic data to this interpretation
limitate later available so I think that
point is it for each application might
call it function there's a clear
explanation how it got there yeah so
there's so many expectations on the
reader in a sense that the well they
don't they can't one applications gonna
have a different type of interpretation
to range interpretation than another one
yes absolutely yeah but I think that's
that's maybe the problem is soils are
complicated and enable makes us
confident in our public educator public
than anyone else trying very hard to do
constantly trying to educate more
general public in these issues yes
what's the distribution of distribution
of actual deep so for the finals vs. you
know is that there's a lot of that
superficial most of these are actually
deep to collect some of the surface soil
samples we don't do too much for them
because we're trying to make full
profile descriptions if there's
something that's got to be just the soil
fertility and organic matter this we
would that's a you have an assembly
problem because you feel that mostly
organic matter to the surface you don't
want to throw that away and so we may
use those and then try to use some kind
of three dimensional interpolation from
the ones we do have to extend those
that's really an active area of research
but the ones we showed there were almost
all at least two Amina with a premiere
experience if complementary models of
crop models or like soil water
assessment tool models are either
limited or productive based on type of
data you have and how available I give a
country doesn't have a lot of oil is
data is that sort of limits the adjacent
well we don't we don't we don't use
ourselves well an application like u
swot let's say they might use that but
these models will have data set lists of
what they need and degree of precision
they're going to need their nice sub
published in fact epic for example
and they made a model they've
representative profiles of the United
States they say these little you can use
these and then you see the but they're
going to need and then he try to develop
another country so they definitely all
have their limitations and you do get
into an area where you know we don't
have sufficient soil data even even the
points or we don't have what you need
yeah I mean they never mentioned
micronutrients somewhere and we don't
think grids we don't make maps let's say
they're doing that we know the measure
of what are we going to do sometimes you
can extrapolate if you make the model
based on other soul factors would be but
again this is I think I mentioned the
uncertainty before this is a very big
challenge is that we might say yeah we
can do something that's good you don't
want to do nothing but we want to tell
our client that there's a lot of
uncertainty here how do we make that
clear to them without them throwing up
their hands and saying oh you're gay or
is it 50 I think the answer is is the
data fit for use and try to communicate
this simulation helps a lot because if
you have a lot of uncertainty what you
can do with our new product you can take
the range we can give you let's say
simple terms maybe mean and standard
deviation you can then run a bunch of
simulations from that probably is
there's a lot of spatial correlation
there's a to actually have simulation
taking about the covariances issue
research traffic right now the hellenic
is working on this site spatial
uncertainty not just administer scary so
i think that's in me so you know where i
am i'm here this semester of the 10th
floor so you're all welcome to come and
see me and please mention the website
did some digging some data and now go
out as citizens of the world
[Music]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu